yeah
crikey et first behind-the-scenes at
Dancing with the Stars with bindi Irwin
and her pro partner Derek Hough I was
truly thrilled when I first found out
that Derek was going to be my pond ah
man she's catching on quick but there
was one challenge bindi immediately had
to tackle Jason we're gonna put you in
these heels and they didn't realize that
I haven't actually want me to pose so I
stood up and they fell down and yeah
that was a good stop I was like that's a
cool move that's like I think that's
like you know what is that I don't know
what that is maybe you're a baby drew up
until recently bindi had never worn high
heels and she's rarely been seen out of
her trademark cast it's kind of nice to
step outside of my comfort zone and try
some sparkles on bindi Irwin has
followed in her dad Steve's footsteps
hosting wildlife series on Australian
and American television the day we
interviewed her was the anniversary of
his 2006 death I heard the dad would be
proud of me because you know he is he's
my superhero and he always will be and
so for us as a family we've tried so
hard to make sure that everything he
loved and lived for carries on